这类骗子。
有几个点。
第一。
陆地。
路径。
第二，团队。
第三，奖励。
奖励或者叫奖品。
啥意思呢？
你去这个寻宝这个路径。
要明确。
我你说为什么说公路片都属于这个类型呢？就是你的路径啊。
公路片的路径是最明确的，就我要到哪去。
对吧。
心花怒放，我要到那个那个那个大理去，路径非常明确。
观众一上来就知道你的路径。
为什么要明确出一个路径呢？
就是在这个地方，这个路径代表主角的。
成长过程。
存长历程。
所以一定要有个明确的路径，对吧？那个。
我们说这个呃金羊毛片子电影金羊毛电影的开山鼻祖。
39年版的。
那个绿叶仙踪。
陶乐斯。
陶老师要去找。
大法师嘛。
到奥兹国嘛。
找大法师。
明确的一个路径。
沿着黄砖走到头。
就能找到。
魔法师。
明确的一个路径。
然后团队。
寻宝片子啊一般来说有它。
一般来说有团。
一个人不好使，最少俩真的最少是双人团队。
你去看那个新华路况俩。
那那个那个那个那那绿野仙踪，那就更不用说了，铁皮人、稻草人、狮子。
再加上陶老师多多5个。
多多不算的话，那也是私人组嘛。
西游记西游记说多少遍了，那是标准的金羊毛啊，标准的金羊毛就是最古老的一种方式，对吧？就是这个他要有个团队。
然后再就是有一个。
肉眼可见的一个奖励，一个奖品。
取经的那个经对吧？然后他要那个呃。
绿叶仙踪要去找大大法师大法师的魔法。
能送他们回家，就是能实现他们的愿望。
那个魔法就很明确的奖奖品奖励很诱人啊，就是那个奖品要很诱人。
我们说抢银行的片子为什么属于金金羊毛骗子？就那个奖品相当有人啊。
那有5000万搁在那儿。
很诱人。
然后就有团队有路径，对吧？就是这是金羊毛类的片子。
爱情片。
我说爱情片啊是唯一一类。
既出现在旧猫咪的分类方式里面，又出现在。
观众角度分类的那个方式里面，爱情片，所以说爱情片还是很硬的，对不对？你咋分都都得有爱情片，王子和公主的故事永远永恒的话题呀，爱情是永恒的话题。
但是说是永恒的话题，因为永恒的话题，所以我把它放在第二个，说是永恒的话题。
这些年可不多了。
爱情片现在越来越少。
其实从90年代以后啊。
近二三十年啊。
现面都相当少。
相当少了。
纯纯的爱情片。
相当少。
爱情电影相当少，但是爱情故事。
是有的，一直存在在影片里。所以这就是我为什么说这10个类型其实10个类型的故事不算10个类型的片子。因为爱情片已经很少了，但是爱情故事。
还是很多的。
我们说爱情故事的元素。
注意的元素什么呢？
我们说一个残缺的。
主角。
一个残缺的主角。
然后一个弥补它的零件儿。
一个弥补他的零件。
啊，然后主角和零件之间其实就是男女主人公嘛。
然后。
两人之间的一条大沟。
一条沟啊。
两个人。
互补。
但是不能在一起。
这就是爱情边的。
全部征地。
全部整理。
所以说这类片子越来越少了，为啥呢？因为这个不管是互补还是这个勾啊，都很难设计了。
在现代社会中啊很难设计的。
我们先说爱情是啥吧啊，你说爱情是啥？
爱情的这个历史啊。
比电影早不了多少年。
爱情是是应该是在也就是118世纪。
从法国。
的文艺作品中。
出来的一个概念。
古代是没有爱情这个概念的。
对吧男女在一块，那叫婚配。
父母。
知命媒妁之言嘛，那叫婚配，没有人说这叫爱情啊。
应该是18世纪吧。
法国这个出来一种新的思潮。
说男女之间有一样东西叫爱情。
然后呢，怎么去描述这个爱情呢？
你去看那个时代的文艺作品啊。
他们初步的时候定义爱情为性冲动。
就是如果一男一女之间。
有性的。
吸引和向往说这叫love。
这叫爱。
而且当时的文艺作品是极其排斥婚内爱的。
就说。
你很难理解这个概念啊，就是说因为爱这个东西出来的时候，他是个独立的人。
东西是是一种新思潮。
他把男女之间的吸引称为爱。
然后呢，迅速的在法国就流行起来，认为哎我跟隔壁的那个王哥有爱。
然后呢大家就觉得哇，你好时尚好高雅啊。
明白这个意思吗？就是他他们认为这是爱。
然后是后来再后来因为需要维护各种社会稳定呀，维护社会和谐呀，又强行的通过一些新的文艺作品，新的思考认为爱。
属于夫妻。
因为夫妻有十万年的历史了，你懂我这个意思吧？
从有人开始，灵长类，从智人开始。
我们说从那个那个智人开始。
八九万年前开始使用使用工具，会说话的那个阶段，就开始一服一起了。
但是爱呢爱情这个玩意儿呢刚出来二三百年。
所以。
爱情啊这个概念。
也就比电影早那么个。
几十年吧，我感觉。
所以他早期的时候是很受电影推崇的。
因为那个时候我们说我们拍一个爱情片，哇啊那。
那是很时髦的话题。
对吧。
但是我感觉爱情的这个劲儿啊。
有点过去了，你想这些年你你。
爱情片已经很少出现了，我不知道同学能不能理解我刚才说的这些啊，就是。
爱情片有点过期了，但是爱情故事还是存在于。
各种电影里面。
为啥这么说？我给大家举个例子啊，我说那个。
泰坦尼克号。
杀人回忆里面是有浓重的。
爱情元素了，因为爱情片这个大电影啊。
又叫情感片。
就说只要是两个人之间浓重的情感啊，都把它归在爱情片里面处理了。
母子情也可以。
兄弟情也可以都可以归在这里面。所以我说像泰坦尼克号。
杀人回忆。
他的嗯主角之间的那种处理方式，用的是爱情故事的思路。
明白吗？
所以我之前说杀人回忆是爱情片，那种说法不太严谨。
有点有有点有点呃有点武断啊，它其实是爱情故事。
爱情故事的处理方式。
纯纯的爱情片已经很少见了。
因为爱情片你要做好这三点是很难的。
就是两个主角之间。
一个有残缺，一个是它的零件很难做到的。
所以我认为现在的爱情片这种做法已经很少了，这是斯奈德。
提出来的啊，其实他说他想表达这个什么意思呢？其实是想表达双方，我们说是这个情感的双方不一定是爱情啊，情感的双方。
互相需要的那个程度很强烈。
就说。
你把这两个看成一个爱情片只要做到两点一。
情感双方互相需要，分不开。
离不开。
明白这意思吗？
2。
他俩不能在一块儿。
就是这个片子最大的张礼。
首先你要拼命的营造他俩离不开。
离不开。
然后再。
给他们制造阻力，他们俩不能在一块。
所以说这是情感类片子。
需要做到的东西。
我们说泰坦尼克号我也说过，我说泰坦尼克号跑上来是爱情片的底子。
他俩是爱情片的底子呀。
互相。
成全互相弥补嘛？你拥有。
我所拥有的我就他俩是互相是是对方的零件。
对吧我是个穷小子。
我最缺的就是钱和地位，其他我什么都有，我有勇气，我有乐观的精神。
我有洒脱的生活态度。
我有一切。
就是没有钱。
然后呢，那个女主角是我有钱，有社会地位，但是我没有快乐，没有自由。
没有追求梦想的勇气和能力和机会。
就是你有的我全都。
没有我想要的你你你都有。
就他俩之间就是互相弥补。所以说我我我说这个斯戴德先生说的主角是残缺的，然后他的另外半是他的零件，我觉得这个说法可以更严谨一点，就是这个那双方互为零件互补是比较好的。
所以你看泰坦尼克号。
跑下来是的。
爱情的底。
然后也不能在一块儿。
不能在一块有沟啊有钩。
但是后来呢他迅速的变成了。
鬼屋了。
迅速变成鬼屋了。
就是灾难来了。
鬼屋片子其实很容易理解啊很容易理解啊鬼屋是什么？
鬼屋是什么片子？
有几个元素啊，一个是一个空间。
一个空间。
对吧一个空间。
然后呢，一个力量。
一个超自然的力量威胁来弄他们。
对吧。
然后呢，一种原罪。
一种原罪。
就是。
在一个密闭的空间里。
来了鬼了。
或者来了一种特别吓人的东西，特别吓人的力量了。
呃。
我们的主角面临生命的危险嘛，密闭空间锁住的呀。
原罪是什么意思呢？就是这个东西啊是你们自己惹来。
是你们自己惹来的，是你们自找的。
是这种片子的一种主题。所以你看泰坦尼克号啊，往往我们把它归在爱情片里。
但其实来。
密闭的空间有没有？
那个船呀你能跑出去啊。
那个游轮你能跑出去吗？
超自然的力量。
冰山。
撞船。
沉默大海。
哪个力量不足以要你的命？
然后原罪。
有没有原罪？
当然有原罪呀。
上来就极力的烘托原罪。
泰坦尼克哈。
世界上最大的一艘游轮。
世界上最豪华的一艘游轮，人类征服自然的标志。
第一次下海。
这就是人类的无知狂妄和对自然缺乏敬畏嘛。
泰坦尼克号上来极力的在宣扬这个元罪啊。
他为什么要说泰坦尼克号是人类征服自然的？
标志性的事件呢。
就是告诉你你要找你你要找死。
你要找死。
所以说鬼物片子。
是这三个元素是核心的一个锁住的空间，一个超自然的力量。还有。
原罪，这一切都是你们自己惹的。所以你看爱情片里的泰坦尼克号，他后半段是不是其实跑到鬼屋去了？
所以我说这个是10种讲故事的方式，并不是10种电影，明白这个意思吗？同样一个电影，泰坦尼克号它前半段，或者是说它既有。
情感故事、爱情故事又有。
鬼屋在。
我们提前把鬼屋说了。
对吧。
超级英雄。
超级英雄也是很古老的故事类型吧。
各种神话传说中，在每一种文化背景的神话传说里，都有超级英雄的片子，对吧？咱们的孙悟空、国外的什么大力神、超人、蜘蛛侠、蝙蝠侠、各个侠嗯整个漫威都是活在超级英雄里边的对吧？当然他也是有有有有有基础的。
我们讲给小朋友听的故事，也很多都是超级英雄。超级英雄片子的要素是什么？我之前其实说过了课程。
我课上说过。
能力。
命门。
对手。
使命？
对吧这是超级英雄片子的。
要素。
侦探类型。
侦探类型片子啊。
啊，也挺古老的。
或者是说也挺典型的吧，看案的嘛。
对吧古古代现在都有啊。
宋词包公对吧？现代的什么福尔摩斯、唐人街探案都属于探案类的片。
看类的片子啊。
呃，三个要素。
三个要素，我看发现斯耐德先生很喜欢用三要素，你发现这个问题了吗？
一个秘密。
一个秘密，一个探秘者。
然后探秘者的自我牺牲。
叛秘者的自我牺牲。
啥意思？
就说你你首先得有个秘密。
这个案子根本看不清啊。
为什么这里叫秘密啊？
观众也不知道。
就是让你观众。
对这个秘密产生了一句，我操，到底谁杀的这个案子到底怎么回事？揭秘嘛？带着观众一起揭秘是这类案子的。
关键点。
拿人的地方打人的地方就上来这个秘密，让观众想知道。然后那谁来解决这个事呢？来了一个探秘者，他可以是一个警察、私家侦探、记者或者就是一个社会青年都可以。反正他他承担了。
带着观众探秘的这个责任，这就是侦探片。
的特点。
这个就回来说那个。
厂银行。
我们说抢银行是金羊毛的骗子。
为什么不在探案片里面？侦探片里面？
我们说那种分类啊，就视频网站那种分类。如果这个片子里面有抢一行，基本上就把它分在最暗题材了。
对不对？
但是在。
故事的1个类型里面，我们把这这个产银行是分在金羊毛的。
因为他没有秘密呀。
主角是这些抢银行的这些贼。
就是你抢的就是你想抢，没有秘密。
他是寻宝明白吗？他只是寻宝的这个方式违法了而已。所以它是金羊毛类的片子。
他案那的片子是什么呢？警察跑到一个银行，发现哎呀这个银行监控毫无。
那个察觉门上也没有撬过的痕迹。
现场也没有任何。
证据，但是一屋子的钱没了。
对吧然后警察局长勃然大怒说必须给我查到。然后银行那些金融大哥说你们查不到就兜着走然后出来一个小警探就说好吧，这个任务就落在我身上。那这个抢银行的案子。
是侦探片。
它是揭秘。
懂我意思吧？你必须有一个秘密，然后有一个探秘者。
自我牺牲啥意思呢？
就是这个探秘者的自我转折。
因为这种故事是从探秘者的角度讲的，所以你这个探秘者在探到一半的时候啊。
必须你需要揭开这个答案的时候，必须做出自我牺牲。
必须改变你平常的行为路径，做出选择。
做出。
正义和真相之间的选择一般是这样的。
或者是真相跟人性之间的一个选择。
这个呃等我具体再给大家说一说，好吧，这是侦探片。
这几个。
呃，要素和窍门这几课信息量很大是吧？听着有点累，是不是？
我们接着往下说啊，回头我统一给大家举一举例子，分析一下好不好？
我们接着往下说啊。
我们说如愿以偿。
也就说这个翻译的不咋地啊，就让人很费解啊，如愿以偿也是个挺常见的类型。你们记不记得第一节课我问你们，你们幻想过吗？
幻想过。
是不是？
琢磨的那些事儿。
万一实现了呢？
那就叫如愿以偿。
就是你想拥有多少钱，他家给你了，西红市首富如愿以偿。
穿越类的片子全部属于。
如愿以偿。
因为穿越你也是想穿越嘛，你想回到小时候呀，那你回去呀，来来来，你回去。
对吧金凯利有好几个片子是如愿以偿。
就我想当上帝来来来，你来来来。
那个那个那个摩平福利慢嘛，说哎，你来吧，你来你来当上帝，你试试，对吧？然后那个金凯丽还有一篇大话王。
对吧他儿子许愿说，我我希望我爸爸永远不会说谎，然后就真的实现了。
他就永远不会说谎了。
如愿以偿，它有几个要素啊，如愿以偿的片子有几个要素，一个愿望。
这个愿望必须是一个。
很多人想过的愿望。
西红市首付那个一大笔钱从天而降，那就是很多人想过这望。所以这个愿望。
必须要有共情。
我想会飞。
啊吧我想当上帝。
这就是是是我想穿越回小时候，重新来过夏洛特烦恼。
愿望。
然后呢，一个咒语。
啥叫咒语啊？其实就是一个规则。
明白吗？规则。
就是你拥有这个实现这个愿望是有一个规则的，是有条件的，是有前提的，不能无法无天，明白这个意思吗？就是把这个愿望的实现增加可信度。
增加可信度。因为实现这个愿望肯定是一个很爽的事情嘛。
上来是个很爽的事情，你不给他不给他点条件和苦头，不给他定一个规则，观众是不买账的。
哦，你说有20亿就有20亿啊，限你30天内花完啊，观众马上觉得，哎嘿嘿看你咋样，对吧？你说给他20亿。
然后呢，没没有，然后就给他。
观众能气死，你知道吧？不行，不行，能给他弄点规则。
所以说这个愿望实现要有个咒语。
要有个咒语，然后如愿以偿类的故事还有个什么要素啊，最后要得到一个教训。
要得长一个教训，啥教训呢？
就是现在挺好。
现在挺好。
别嘚瑟。
别要冤枉了，现在挺好，你去看大话王，你去看冒牌天神，你去看夏洛特烦恼。
你去看西红市首富。
沈腾那片子沈腾成名的几个片子，全是如愿以偿。
你有没有发现？
穿越的西红市首富的沈腾的片子都是如愿以偿。
对吧。
就是。
先实现这个愿望，但这个愿望有代价了，有规则了。
最后得到教训。
什么用啊？
珍惜当下。
熟愿以茶类的片片子，最后的主题往往是珍惜眼前人。
对不对？夏洛特反感珍惜眼镜。我说沈腾的片子都是如愿以偿。
他这是有套路的。你看那个那个呃我们说周星驰的片子。
啊，周星驰的片段没讲到，我们说那个。
那个那个。
金羊毛类的片子，徐峥的片子。
徐峥的片子啊大部分都是金羊谋。
他吃这一口。
你知道吗？那个沈腾吃这一口。
就是他都是如愿以偿。
爱走这一口。
然后呢，麻烦家伙是什么呢？就是周星驰爱走的路线。
周星驰爱走的路线。
其实麻烦翻译的特别不好。
不应该翻译成麻烦家伙，是家伙遇麻烦。
是家伙遇到麻烦，是这么理解，麻烦家伙。
一般是什么呢？一个小人物摊上一个大事儿。
熟不熟？小人物遇大事，熟不熟？
是吧一般是这种类型。
我们说这种片子有什么要素呢？
就是这个人要无辜。
一个无辜的家伙。
他越无辜，越无害，无害，懂我意思吧？无害很很普通，很善良。就是我说的小人物，明白这个意思吧？
然后一个突然的麻烦，我们说叫从天而降。
从天而降一个突然的麻烦。
然后最后。
关乎生死生死考验。
就是这类片子。
的基本套路要素。
很多喜剧片。
是这样的。
周星驰的片子全是这样。
大部分吧。
一个很无辜的人。
从天而降的麻烦，那不知道招谁惹谁了，对吧？然后呢，最后生死大战呢。
生死大展，但不是所有的麻烦家伙都是喜剧片啊，绝不是啊你孩子让人绑架了，救小孩的那种片子，那那的这生死营救什么的之类的都是麻烦家伙呀。
一个无辜的人。
从天而降一个麻烦。
然后这个这个是。
呃，关乎生死对吧？家里出事了什么的，那都属于麻烦，也就家伙愈麻烦，就是有一个人好烟烟的突然出事了。
这种故事。
它也是一个很古老的故事类型。所以我为什么反复强调说，他这个分类方法可取之处就是它是从讲故事角度分的。因这种故事也是人家愿意听的呀。
明白这个意思吗？
变签仪式。
哎呀，一听又。
听不懂是不是？
我觉得他这是就是翻译的严重有问题。
来，我们说变签仪式是什么类型啊？
我这么说吧。
就生活中的一个问题，这个问题很常见，但是你的处理方式。
不对。
明白这个意思吗？
你看啊，我们这么说吧，就说一个常见的问题。
然后你用一个非常规的方式。
去处理了。
对吧那是。
可不可以理解为过激行为呢？
我之前跟你们说过的那种过激的行为呢。
然后最终要回归正确的方法。
回归正确的方法。
就这种类型的片子其实也是非常常见的。它在古老的故事里面不常见，但是在电影故事在现实题材中是非常多的，是这几年是非常多的这种题材的片子，比如说录取通知书。我给大家举过这个例子，想考大学。
就就是想考大学的问题是个很常见的。
家庭问题很容易理解这个问题本身很容易理解。然后呢，他们伪造了一个大学，他并没有。
采用常用的手段伪造了一个大学。
实际上是一种。
过激的行为，同时也是一种。
责任的逃避。
所以在教材上，他认为我这个过激行为往往是一个逃避行为。你当然可以那么去理解啊，他逃避了，他没有用正确的方法解决，他当然是逃避。
最后他要回归，就这帮人开始真的努力学习之后，反而把这个假的大学。
给搞成了一个真的大学。
我说这就是。
所谓的变迁意识。
能理解吗？
还有还有一个片子很红的，我不知道你们看没看过，叫触不可及。
就是一个全身瘫痪的一个富豪。
然后雇佣了一个这个呃刑满释放的一个。
小是街头小痞子。
一个一个黑人，对，原版是法国片。
然后美国也翻拍了。
美国版是凯文哈特演的。
凯文哈特跟那个绝命毒师的那个老白演。
嗯，讲的就是一个富豪全身瘫痪。然后呢。
对生活已经失去了。
信心了。
然后雇佣了一个黑人。
刑满释放的一个黑人年轻人做他的看护，这人毫无经验，也做不了看护。
这就是一个变迁意识的。他他的问题就是我瘫痪了。
我瘫痪了。
不想活了，我想死。
想死呢，但是自己又死不了呀，没有手段呀。他就说那我就雇一个。
不负责任的。
私人看护师。
让他一失误把我弄死得了，然后他就雇了一个最不靠谱的。
这个这个看护士，一般你不得雇一个四五十岁的老娘们干这种事儿嘛，对不对？阿姨什么的，对吧？比较细心嘛。
他就雇1个20多岁的刚刑满释放的黑人小伙。
但是最后反而这个黑人小伙子把他照顾的很好，用自己另类的方式把他照顾的很好，然后回归面对这个问题，就是我瘫痪了又怎样呢？我还是要努力的生活。
就在回归。
这就是所谓的变迁意识，这么理解能理解吧？这名字不需要去记啊，因为太难记了。
你就记这种。
寻常问题。
过激行为解决，最后回归正确方法。
好吧，包括麻烦家伙也是就是家伙遇麻烦，小人物一出大事就是这个类型。
如愿以偿也是啊，就这种名字。